this
is tristan de montebello he's a very
interesting guy based in los angeles
california and one day he decided to
challenge his skills on public speaking
tristan did not have any experience in
the field however
he decided to compete in toastmasters
world championship the most famous
public speaking competition in the world
he managed to become public speaking
expert within a few months and
eventually he made it into the top 10.
how did he achieve all that the answer
is scott young
one of the most famous self-development
bloggers out there
and a person that devoted his life in
creating strategies on how to accelerate
the process of learning
his most recent book ultra learning is
considered the autodux stream
it's a manual that offers concrete and
practical advice
on how to learn anything fast it draws
inspiration from scott's own experience
and also from significant figures across
history
that managed to transcend the norm and
showcase unprecedented mastery
in their field of choice i love the idea
of ultra learning because learning in
itself
is an activity absolutely elemental to
our existence
thus taking learning to the next level
isn't something trivial
rather it is something that can prove
momentous in one's life
prefix meta comes from the greek word
meta which means
beyond we use meta to signify something
related to itself i
something self-referential in our case
meta learning means learning about
learning or
learning how to learn so again the idea
of meta learning
is that if you're going to embark on a
learning project you should first spend
a little bit of time learning how to do
the learning project that seems a little
bit
recursive but it's also obvious because
if you're going to learn
a new language and you've never done
this before there's many many many ways
to do it and many many pitfalls and so
if you spend a couple hours doing
research ahead of time
you're going to get a much more
optimized path forward than if you
just oh this is the first book i saw
this is the first resource they saw or
oh this app seems to be popular let's
download it like that approach to to
learning things which is what most
people do
the acquisition of every skill in the
beginning seems like a strenuous act
the only way to ameliorate this process
is to understand the mechanics of the
skill first
learn how to learn is the basic motto
behind ultra learning
and the core idea that needs to be
espoused before embarking on a learning
journey
in scott's words meta learning forms the
map
showing you how to get to your
destination without getting lost
when bill gates first met warren buffett
their host at dinner
gate's mother asked everyone around the
table to identify what they believed was
the single most important factor
in their success through life gates and
buffett gave the same one-word answer
focus there's nothing more powerful than
focus in life
i can personally attest to that and the
aforementioned parable
reinforces my point focus isn't an easy
thing and it often constitutes a form of
superpower in a distraction-oriented
world
every one of us has to face daily
numerous obstacles that impede our
ability to stay concentrated in a task
obstacles like procrastination inability
to maintain focus
and even a failure to create the right
kind of focus but this can be normal
especially when we face novelty and
challenges that seem arcane to our
environment
resistance starts to creep in and our
ability to focus suffers as a result
there is no easy way to tackle that
conundrum we need to just accept it as a
standard tenet of the learning process
and quit being too judgmental with
ourselves whenever we fail to overcome
it
as code states in the book recognize
where you are and start small
if you're the kind of person who can't
sit still for a minute try sitting still
for half a minute
half a minute soon becomes one minute
then two
over time the frustrations you feel
learning a particular subject may become
transmuted into genuine interest
one of the major issues one has to face
when dealing with a new skill is that of
directness
directness refers to the ability of the
learner to approach the most crucial
aspects of the skill head-on
usually instead of immersing ourselves
in the skill itself
we try to find shortcuts or hacks that
can make the skill easier to acquire
scott explains that beautifully in the
book we want to speak a language but try
to learn mostly by playing fun
apps rather than conversing with actual
people
we want to work on collaborative
professional programs but mostly code
scripts in isolation
we want to become great speakers so we
buy a book on communication rather than
practice presenting
in all these cases the problem is the
same directly learning the thing we want
feels too uncomfortable boring or
frustrating
so we settle for some book lecture or
app hoping it will eventually make us
better at the real thing
the best way to learn directly is to
immerse in projects relevant to the
field from the beginning
despite the innate challenging nature of
such an endeavor
the benefits are immense
benjamin franklin was considered by many
the greatest polymath of all time
he was a politician and entrepreneur an
inventor and a great writer
especially when it came to writing
franklin would constantly try to come up
with methods that would allow him to
improve this extremely important skill
for instance he would read the spectator
and he would take notes on articles that
appeared there
he would then leave the notes for a few
days and come back to them
trying to reconstruct the original
article from memory by doing this many
times
he would familiarize himself with the
concepts and eventually automate the
ways he would internalize them
such a method is considered a drill and
drills allow you through repetition
to improve on weaknesses in your
learning process drilling is really
i think a lot of us have a bad feeling
about drills we remember
you know doing our times tables when we
were kids or
memorizing something and it feels like
drudgery it doesn't feel as fun
and often it feels like it's tedious or
unnecessary
and i think the problem is that if you
just give someone a drill and say okay
you're going to do this 100 times
then they often don't know why they're
learning it and it's often not driven by
any
kind of need it's just that's what's
next on the list to learn is do this
drill 100 times
and the way i like to think of drills is
that if you do drills properly in an
ultra learning project then
they actually feel super useful because
what you're doing is that you're
encountering some real learning
challenge
it's too difficult and so you're
breaking it apart or breaking it down so
that you're working on a simpler
aspect and then going back and trying to
reintegrate it to to work back into the
original problem
let's say you're a student and you have
to prepare for an exam
you have three different options i
propose how to allocate your time
passive review go over your notes in the
book
create a concept map write down the main
concepts in the diagram and see how
they're related to each other
and free recall retrieve the knowledge
from the book or remember
what was in it passive review and
concept mapping are inefficient
free recall is the best way to go human
beings can't know with confidence how
well they've learned something instead
they need to constantly test their
knowledge by evaluating how easy it is
to remember it
the thing is is that free recall is
actually a lot more similar to what you
actually have to do on tests
and it's a lot more similar to what you
have to do in real life very often is
that
it's not just merely oh i'm looking at
this information have i seen this before
which is what the sort of self-check is
when you're reviewing
but here's a question what's the answer
or
can you activate this knowledge without
having it in front of you and that is a
much more difficult task
and it's something that you actually
have to actively practice
i told chris rock i was going to the
comedy cellar here in new york he said
i'm going to come down i said christy
i'm working on some stuff come down
i want to know what you think we're
close and we always give each other
opinions on what we're doing and
where we feel this can go or that can go
just punch up so he comes down
he's like oh my god kev funny i said you
going up he said yeah i'ma try some
stuff out too chris goes up
dave pops in later that night me and
chris were there talking chappelle comes
in
we say you going up he said yeah me and
chris go downstairs
so we can watch dave keep in mind me and
chris are excited we just worked on new
material
right chris gave me some good beats he
went on i gave him some good beats
dave went on stage and was so good
right and me and chris just took what we
had we balled it up
we threw it away we threw it in the
trash we threw it
i said i said i'm so disgusted with
where my level of thinking was
after seeing where dave was i gotta go
back in the gym
comedy cellar is a comedy club in new
york it is designed for a small crowd
and famous comedians go there to test
new material
it is the best way for them to gather
feedback and evaluate whether or not the
new material is worth using in bigger
shows
feedback constitutes a great way to
assess one's level of competence in any
field
but feedback can be tricky what is good
feedback and what isn't
scott has done extensive research on the
topic and his analysis can be very
enlightening
a lot of feedback isn't actually very
helpful and
if the feedback distracts from your
ability to do the task
or worse it has a demotivating influence
on your performance
then it can actually be bad and so if i
tell you
for instance oh you're so great at this
you're so smart
when you're learning as a teacher that
actually has a negative effect one of
those things that they found was praise
is not useful for students because
praise if it doesn't have any
information the student can use to
improve
has a demotivating effect oh i'm doing
this really well okay i'm not going to
work so hard now
and so i thought that was really
interesting because we often know that
really harsh and critical feedback
you're such an idiot you know
no one wants to hear that but also the
opposite is also
not great for feedback either feedback
can oftentimes make us feel
harsh and uncomfortable ego usually gets
in the way as well as the intentions and
experience of the person offering
feedback
extracting the signal from the noise can
be challenging but it is a challenge
we ought to embrace
nigel richards is a scrabble legend they
call him the tiger woods of scrabble but
clearly only referencing tiger's
abilities on the green cause listen to
these numbers
richards has won the thailand king's cup
11 times the uk opened six times
the u.s national championship five times
the english world championships three
times and his most recent victory was
the french world championship against an
actual french-speaking player
a friend of his told the new zealand
herald that richard studied the french
scrabble dictionary for eight weeks
specifically to learn the words and not
the language i guess some of the
language rubbed off on him because
richards actually won a challenge
against his opponent who
just a reminder could speak french nigel
richards
obviously possesses a great memory but
that's not what made him a scrabble
champion
in one of his interviews richards said
the following it's hard work
you have to have dedication to learn
elsewhere adding
i'm not sure there is a secret it's just
a matter of learning the words
it's self-evident that the learning
ethos combined with a good memory can
help you go a long way
you forget for different reasons like
time overriding old memories with new
ones or
inability to access specific parts of
your memory however
memory despite its obscure nature can be
manipulated through different mechanisms
mechanisms like spacing
proceduralization overlearning and
mnemonics
these are all great techniques used by
ultra learners
they can effectively counteract your
short and long term
rates of forgetting and end up making a
huge difference in your memorization
richard feynman was one of the most
beautiful minds of the previous century
what made him such a prolific figure
amongst scientists
wasn't just his intelligence but also
his unparalleled ability to continuously
seek
knowledge but if you realize all the
time what's kind of wonderful
that as we expand our experience into
wilder and wilder regions of experience
every once in a while we have these
integrations in which everything is
pulled together in a unification
which it turns out to be simpler than it
looked before
the surface wasn't of interest to him
what mattered the most was how deep he
could delve into a problem
because if you go deep enough anything
can become interesting
and through depth you develop intuition
intuition occurs when we do things
naturally
when there is no struggle entailed in
our thinking process
when you do and feel things intuitively
you operate on a level beyond
comprehension
it is a level where you know the outcome
of something before you even deal with
it
this is the secret behind most geniuses
and this is probably the first step
into any form of mastery
this is the starry night one of my
favorite paintings and a piece of art
that along with others made vincent van
gogh
one of the most influential painters
across space and time
van gogh was a prodigy of his time he
started painting at the age of 26
with no previous experience in any form
of art
and within 10 years he managed to ascend
to the upper echelons of the art
scene of his era the sad thing however
is that
like many great artists van gogh was
celebrated the most
posthumously during his life he was
considered weird and crazy by some
he was extremely introverted and shy and
more often than not
he would be isolated by his peers what
kept him going was his unfaltering
obsession with drawing
he would draw for days straight changing
sceneries and persistently trying to
improve his style
scott in his book raises a great point
with regards to van gogh's evolution
how can we explain these discrepancies
how does someone who starts late
with no obvious talent and many
handicaps nonetheless become one of the
world's greatest artists
with one of the most recognizable and
distinctive styles
of course tenacity played a significant
role in his development
but most importantly it was his
willingness to constantly experiment
that made him stand out so
fast to really master something to
really reach the levels of creativity
and genius that we associate with the
kind of end products of a learning goal
you really need to experiment because
eventually you get onto a path that no
one's been here before
right when you are mastering a skill at
that high level
you are doing something that no one's
done before so learning in that sense is
not something you can just
ask some expert what's the right way to
learn this because you are often
approaching limits of things
that you know no one has done it exactly
that way before so you have to sort of
develop that approach yourself
all of these principles are only
starting points the art of learning will
always be projecting new challenges to
one's life
but when you get the fundamentals right
the substrate becomes more solid and you
become more ready to engross yourself
into new ideas and skills
and as god eloquently suggests towards
the end of the book
true mastery comes not just from
following the path thrown
by others but also from exploring
possibilities they haven't yet imagined